le corps de robert boulin a été retrouvé
ce matin vers 9h dans un étang de la
forêt de rambouillet désir soir des
recherches avaient été lancées car un
des collaborateurs de robert boulin
avait retrouvés dans le bureau du
ministre un message écrit de sa main
précisant son intention de mettre fin à
ses jours en forêt de rambouillet
monsieur voulait est arrivé par ce
chemin volant de sa 305 jusqu'au bord de
l'étang rompu située en forêt de
rambouillet c'est un lieu qu'il
connaissait bien pour l'avoir parcouru à
cheval il ya plusieurs années
après avoir rédigé un bref message
d'adieu à sa famille pour dos duquel il
précisait que les clés de sa voiture
était dans la poche arrière de son
pantalon il a semble-t-il absorbé des
barbituriques fermer les portes hier de
sa voiture à clef puis s'est avancé vers
l'étang au centre duquel les gendarmes
l'ont retrouvé ce matin après plus de
trois heures de recherches le corps de
monsieur boulin se trouvait à cinq
mètres du rivage
repêché par les pompiers il était
ensuite transportés à bord d'un
hélicoptère vers l'institut médico légal
après cette mort on sent ce soir qu'une
polémique vive dur est prête à s'engager
le directeur de minute justifie
l'attitude de son journal celui du
canard enchaîné se défend d'avoir
calomnié au passage il attaque les
moyens officiels et officieux commune
lee d'information parce qu'ils ont fait
un rapprochement certains d'entre eux du
moins un rapprochement avec l' affaire
salengro
vous savez le ministre du front
populaire qui s'était suicidé en 1937
par une campagne de presse féroce le
faisaient apparaître comme traître lors
de la guerre pour notre part à vous qui
nous regarde et nous vous laisserons
soigneusement la dure et serait une
réflexion malgré le drame qui conduira
sereine réflexion sur ce drame qui
conduira à votre propre jugement
pardon nous ferrons juste observer au
passage sans nous mêler de ce qu'ont dit
nos confrères sont jugés leur liberté ça
les regarde que le moment n'est pas venu
de mettre tout le monde dans le même
panier des censeurs comme l'a dit le
canard ce soir puisque les journalistes
de télévision peut être droit eux aussi
à leur part de respectabilité
ces deux batailles là deux soeurs en
tout cas pas celle de cette rédaction
pour refermer cette édition spéciale
passons à autre chose de plus
constructif laissons parler un homme qui
a bien de la sagesse ce soir bien de la
tolérance aussi me semble-t-il le fils
bertrand belin un homme de coeur qui
passe sa vie depuis dix ans au service
des enfants et qui me semble faire
preuve dans sa douleur et son chagrin
d'une très belle
élévation d'esprit dont on peut
simplement ce n'était on est mise en
cause ça l'a bouleversée pourtant c'est
un homme qui a donné l'image d'un jardin
solidaire baissier c'est un geste qui
ressemble fort c'est vous faire une
confidence
on a beau être seul lorsque l'on vient
sur un certain nombre de terrains et
veulent ses parents et ses mots y vit
six data
malgré votre solidité et je dirais à
cause
lycée car l'équilibré à jean à cause de
cette série si tu crois qu'on est frac
et fois que comme p les chênes qu'on
abat
un coup laisse pas dans un chêne il peut
s'abattre filin d'un quand même si sedan
est mauvais et je crois que c'est ce qui
m'est arrivé et c'est une tragédie pour
nous tous on nous sommes bouleversés
nous sommes terrifiés mesures et on est
inquiet aussi parce que fait-on abattre
des hommes comme lui ça me paraît très
grave alors bien aujourd'hui on l'avenir
on cherchera des responsabilités mais ce
que je veux dit en tant que fils et il
faut le prendre comme tel c'est que il
était d'abord c'est un homme je me sens
vous faire de confidences qui est depuis
longtemps dans mes buts pour les enfants
maïs est entièrement affectivement
amicalement
c'est une perte immense pour nous manque
et c'est une tragédie mais je suis
inquiet parce que je ne saisis pas bien
ce qui a pu la battre
or ces attaques alors justement venant
sont à ses attaques à ce qui fait dire
tout à l'heure à raymond barre que ce
suicide était la conséquence de
certaines ignominie et d'une grande
bassesse à ce qui a fait dire aussi à
jacques chaban delmas qu'on pourrait
presque parler d'assassinât tous
concentre vraisemblement autour d'un
dossier celui de l'achat d'un terrain et
de la construction de la résidence
secondaire de robert boulin à ramatuelle
près de saint-tropez paul lefèvre nous
explique maintenant les aspects
techniques devaient les voir assez
complexe de ce dossier révélé par la
presse il ya une quinzaine de jours
environ
cette maison de vacances est sans doute
devenu le cauchemar de robert boulin
mais elles n'existaient pas en 1967
lorsque la sphère du val de bois à
débuter à cette date là à promoteur
henry tournée était propriétaire de 36
hectares à ramatuelle pour lequel il
obtient un permis de construire un
lotissement
mais comme henri tournet tarder à
construire un lotissement le permis
devient caduque et une nouvelle
réglementation en 68 lui interdit dit
fier le projet dans cette affaire il
semble d'ailleurs que henry tournée est
toujours cherché à faire pression sur
verre boulin pour obtenir malgré la
nouvelle réglementation à nouveau permis
de construire pour son lotissement
toujours est il qu'en janvier ce centre
henri tournée vans la plus grosse partie
du terrain soit une trentaine d'hectares
à trois hommes d'affaires normand qui
croyait distille encore qu'on pouvait
toujours construire sur ce terrain et
même avec un projet de lotissement
cette vente n'est pas enregistrés au
bureau des hypothèques de draguignan
pour des raisons qui ne sont pas très
claires mais dès ce moment là les trois
acheteurs normands se croit propriétaire
du terrain alors que henry tournée
prenant prétexte que cette vente n'a pas
été enregistrée revendre une nouvelle
fois le terrain à une société suisse
holy tour dont on dit par ailleurs qu'il
serait l'actionnaire majoritaire
rien ne prouve que robert boulin et
d'été au courant de cette double vente
lorsqu'en 1981 il achète à la société
suisse
holy tour 2 hectares à cet endroit pour
y construire une villa et le ministre
inspectant la nouvelle réglementation
présente un projet et obtient son permis
de construire édifices et maisons de
vacances mais les trois acheteurs
normand conteste tout de suite la vente
et par le fait même la validité du
permis de construire obtenu par robert
boulin en 1975 sur plainte de la chambre
des notaires de la manche
une information est ouverte qui débouche
après quelques péripéties qui débouche
le 12 juin 79 sur deux inculpations
l'inculpation de m groult le notaire qui
a enregistré qui a accepté d'enregistrer
la vente entre henri tournée et holly
tour et sur l'inculpation aussi d'henri
tournée accusé d'avoir vendu deux fois
le même terrain
c'est le notaire des acquéreurs qui m'a
demandé ainsi qu'un jeu
breton ce qui m'a demandé de revendre
cette ces terrains là les tickets vendus
par acte non publiée qui m'a demandé à
les revendre in situ du tout parce qu'il
pensait que cela pouvait régulariser
l'opération depuis 1976 robert boulin
tenter de savoir à l'air à l'aide d'un
notaire de kokkola s'il était réellement
propriétaire de son terrain si sa
parcelle faisait partie des 30 hectares
vendue une première fois henri tourner
autre d'acheteurs normand il semble
qu'une étude de jérôme est établi le 13
janvier 118 et révélé que le terrain
boulin était en effet vendu deux fois
par henri tournée il semble aussi que
les trois acheteurs normand et
refusaient d'échanger de terrain moulin
contre un terrain libre l'information
l'anc est en cours démontrera si
l'ensemble de ces opérations et avait
été portée à la connaissance du ministre
du travail
il en est en tout cas toujours défendre
robert boulin s'est il suicidé ou a t'il
en fait été assassiné plus de quatre ans
après les faits un second rapport d
autopsie du corps de l'ancien ministre
du travail de valéry giscard d'estaing
paraît contredire l'hypothèse du suicide
en tout cas aux yeux de sa famille est
le fils de robert boulin n'hésitent pas
aujourd'hui à lier la disparition de son
père à la sphère des avions renifleurs
d'elf aquitaine
marcel trillât et jean marc dubois
c'est ici en forêt de rambouillet que
l'on avait retrouvé le corps de robert
boulin le 9 octobre 1979 à 9 heures du
matin sur le bord de l'étang de hollande
la mort remontait à la veille au soir
dans sa voiture un bristol portant
quelques mots d'adieu à sa famille très
vite les enquêteurs concluent au suicide
par noyade
d'autant plus que robert boulin qui
était l'objet d'une campagne de presse
avait écrit la veille plusieurs lettres
dans lesquelles il annoncé son intention
d'en finir mais le 7 juin 1983 bertrand
belin le fils de l'ancien ministre sa
soeur et sa mère dépose une plainte
contre x pour homicide volontaire le 29
octobre dernier le corps est exhumé et
une nouvelle autopsie est pratiquée
les experts relèvent d'abord l'absence
dans le rapport de la première autopsie
de toute analyse des poumons qui aurait
pourtant permis de conclure si robert
boulin était mort par noyade ou non les
contrôles radiologiques leur permettent
surtout de constater deux fractures
l'une des os du nez
l'autre de la mâchoire or au moment du
décès le procureur de la république
avait interdit l'examen du crâne les
constatations qui rendent de plus en
plus fragile la thèse du suicide mais
s'il ne s'agit pas là celui-ci c'est
évidemment un assassinat pour l'instant
nous sommes sur ce sont les médecins qui
emploie le mot de coûts directs et
violent il dit envisage également
l'hypothèse d'une chute sur un objet
contendant mais je connais bien les
lieux il n'y a pas de sol dur ou
d'objets contendants donc il a été battu
battu
nous n'avons pas la preuve de la phase
iib là mais cette thèse là et quand même
en train de se vérifier vos beaux par
hbo s'il y a assassinat quel serait
alors le mobile
alors vous savez ça c'est en effet
compliqué ce que je peux vous dire d'une
manière très claire c'est que mon père
c'est ed a perçu comme l'avait écrit je
ne parle pas de lettre posthume
mais comme il l'avait écrit déjà que ses
propres amis politiques l'avait trahi un
homme qui se sent trahi qui se sent
attaqué peut se défendre et bien entendu
à ce moment là donnez des dossiers si
ces dossiers étaient trop importants eh
bien on peut comprendre qu'on les tue et
je ne dis pas que c'est ça je dis que
c'est une thèse et une thèse qui se
vérifie chaque jour lors ces dossiers ce
sont des dossiers concernait toute une
série d'affaires financières je vous dis
ça j'ai l'air très sûr de moi mais je le
suis parce que ce sont des dossiers que
j'avais vu dans son coffre alors que ça
concernait quoi ils qui ça c'est
compliqué parce que quand vous voyez
quelque chose d'écrit j'ai vu sécurité
sociale un jour une autre fois j'ai vu
elle fera une autre fois j'ai vu une
entreprise qui est aujourd'hui
nationalisées mais qu'il n'était pas à
l'époque
eh bien à chaque fois on a vu ça a
effectivement mais sont des dossiers
kaminis des finances puisque avant
d'être au travail et ministre des
finances a normalement c'est nous qui en
déduisons que c'était ça la faire beau
linge une affaire judiciaire qui
pourrait bien dans les jours qui
viennent connaître des prolongements sur
le terrain politique
l' affaire boulin tout de suite je vous
propose d'écouter une interview donc de
jongh lalande l'inde et beau frère de
robert boulin ce dernier n'y va pas par
quatre chemins
jacques chaban-delmas l'a déclaré en 79
écoutez bien ça s'est passé à barsac le
soir des obsèques en gironde devant la
famille connaître l'assassin de mon beau
frère
je m'en souviens une nouvelle pièce que
vert se maintenant à ce dossier et faire
3 aquitaine jean lalonde au cours de la
conversation je sais qu'il a parlé et la
dirm on en est en regardant ma soeur
colette boulin il lui a dit robert avec
un dossier et si vous trouvez ce dossier
vous aurez la clé et nous pourrons agir
si si vous ne trouvez pas un des jeunes
à ne pouvoir rien faire et je ne lèverai
pas le petit doigt
bon ceci au moment donné il a parlé il a
dit il ya menace à ça et il est
dangereux
je me souviens je ne suis plus le
contexte l'ordre des phrases je ne peux
pas le nommer mais je me souviens cela
ça m'avait frappé c'est la raison pour
laquelle je m'en souviens il vous a donc
bien affirmé qu'il connaissait
l'assassin qui connaissait dillane
assassin il est dangereux de faire et
dire qu'il est dangereux peut peut-être
vouloir dire et qui le connaissaient je
ne veux pas interpréter sa pensée moi je
les prix comme étant je ne croyais pas
au suicide de mon beau frère
je ne voulais pas y croire et je
continue à ne pas y croire et j'ai pris
cela comme
je vais penser que président chaban
delmas connaissait bien des choses
pourquoi avez vous attendu aujourd'hui
pour faire ces déclarations parce qu'on
ne me l'a pas demandé et quand je n'ai
faire parler un moment donné la fin
après les obstacles
il fallait attendre de toute façon je ne
le pensais qu'il y allait avoir une
instruction qu'il y avait et que l'on
allait interroger que de tout allait
être remués comme seul est aujourd'hui
on n en a rien été et par la suite ma
famille ma soeur et mes neveux
non pas et j'étais choqué on est à deux
et ils n'ont pas ils n'ont pas bougé ils
n'ont pas réagi immédiatement en plus il
avait des pressions et des menaces qui
sait que on a attendu le magazine
l'express relance la sphère boulin
l'ancien ministre contrairement à la
thèse officielle ne s'est peut-être pas
suicidé et pour appuyer cette thèse
le journaliste james sarrazin révèle un
détail dans le rapport d'autopsié que
tout le monde avait négligé jusque là je
résume
d'après l'autopsié il serait tombé sur
le dos je parle de monsieur boulin il
serait tombé sur le dos après sa mort or
la thèse officielle et qu'il est mort le
corps en avant conclusions de
l'enquêteur on a déplacé et le corps
entre le moment où il est mort et le
moment où on l'a retrouvé par conséquent
il est difficile de défendre la thèse du
suicide dit le journaliste commentaires
jean daniel flaysakier dans les heures
qui suivent la mort d'une personne et du
fait de l'arrêt du coeur apparaissent
dans certaines zones du corps des
connexions sanguine sorte d'hématomes et
qu'on appelle lividités cadavériques des
liquidités qui sont immuables robert
boulin fut découvert mort dans la
position de la prière musulmane
il aurait donc dû présenter des
liquidités sur le ventre la face et les
tibias
or les deux légistes ont constaté
l'existence de les visiter dans la
partie postérieure du corps de la
l'hypothèse que formulent certain robert
boulin ne serait pas mort dans la
position où il fut découvert et son
corps aurait été retourné
si on ajoute à cela que les viscères de
robert boulin et en particulier ses
poumons et étrangement disparu
on comprendra que la bataille d'experts
pour déterminer la cause du décès de
l'ancien ministre n'est pas prêt d'être
terminé
la sphère boula le parquet a requis vous
savez un non-lieu reste maintenant au
juge d'instruction à se prononcer pour
soi un complément d'enquêté
où classer l affaire cette décision du
ministère public du parc et scandalise
la famille de l'ancien ministre je vous
propose d'écouter maintenant colette
boulin l'épousé de l'ancien maire de
libourne
je suis scandalisé bien entendu d'abord
ya des années que je joue scandalise les
et ce réquisitoire à mon avocat s'est
précipitée qui a pris aussi par la
télévision s'est précipité au parquet et
a pu lire ce réquisitoire et j'ai cru
comprendre que c'était un très mauvais
roman de la part du parquet qui ne
répond à aucune des questions
essentielles car vous savez qu'il y
avait 40 anomalie les principales sont
les fractures de la face ce sont les
divinités
mon mari a été trouvé mort sur le ventre
et j'avais des divinités dans le doubs
or normalement il aurait dû le savoir
sur le ventre et puis il y a dans le
dossier il appert d'une façon formelle
que les gens qui sont allés chercher mon
mari était plein de boue avait de la
boue jusqu'à mi-cuisse dans les 60
centimètres d'eau bon eh bien mon mari
n'avait debout ni sur les vêtements ses
mocassins était resté à ses pieds et y
avait aucune trace de boue ce qui prouve
bien que j'ai raison qu'il a été
assassiné qu'il y à des assassins
je ne sais pas pourquoi on les protège
et que nous mais tout que des entraves
pour le pas que nous nous trouvions
cette vérité que nous cherchons et comme
découvriront je suis formel il
s'arrêtera en octobre 79e de l'être le
corps sans vie de robert moulin de
lutter retrouver dans 50 cm d'eau d'un
étang forêt de rambouillet
robert boulin tamuda milices du général
de biens de pompidou et de giscard
d'estaing mais il s'étend de carrière
miriel mana suicide pour les autorités
ce livre pourrait relancer la faire pour
son auteur de trop nombreux éléments
n'ont pas été prises en compte
d'abord le témoignage d'un ancien
assistant des médecins légistes qui
explique qu'il y avait des cours
sur le crâne de robert boulin une
estafilade sur le poignet droit du
ministre
et pour lui c'est clair le ministre a
été assassiné aujourd'hui ce qui est
aberrant c'est de voir que cette affaire
n'a jamais vraiment été instruites comme
une commune aurait fallu c'est à dire on
n'a pas vérifié tout simplement s'il y
avait une noyade hier s'il n'y avait pas
de l'eau dans les poumons
istres tous les scellés judiciaires ont
été volés illégales les dossiers du
ministre ont tous disparu rien n'a été
fait en fait pour vraiment connaître la
vérité
un sentiment partagé par la fille de
robert boulin qui se bat depuis 27 ans
pour connaître la vérité le corps de mon
père a été retrouvée officiellement à
20h45 mardi matin et monsieur raymond
barre monsieur bonnet qui était à ce
moment là aussi me lisent à l'intérieur
tous ces gens étaient au courant de la
découverte du corps de mon père
sept heures avant la découverte
officielle
alors oui déjà dès le départ les choses
n'étaient pas normales et il était non
seulement au courant qu'on a retrouvé le
corps mais en plus qu'il s'était suicidé
par barbituriques
à l'époque le ministre est cité dans une
affaire immobilière frauduleuses
ce qui aurait motivé son geste et à
laquelle ne croit plus la famille robert
boulin aurait été en possession de
dossiers compromettants pour certains
dirigeants du rpr
fort de ces faits nouveaux la famille
réclame une réouverture de l'instruction
près de trente ans après les faits la
justice va-t-elle ouvrir une instruction
sur l' affaire boulin le procureur
rentrer à sa décision cet après midi à
la demande de fabienne boulin la fille
de l'ancien ministre qui s'appuie sur de
nouveaux éléments est convaincu que son
père ne s'est pas suicidé pour elle il
s'agit d'un assassinat
joseph tual et khalid out haye fabienne
boulin ne croit pas au suicide de son
père robert goulet en octobre 1979 le
ministre du travail de valéry giscard
d'estaing est retrouvé mort dans un
étang de la forêt de rambouillet après
un premier rendez vous au mois de juin
dernier
elle sera reçue cet après midi par le
procureur général de paris je suis assez
sereine du fait que nous avons des faits
nouveaux qui sont considérables et qui
justifie une réouverture de
l'instruction
monsieur dur a remis ces faits le
témoignage du premier ministre de
l'époque raymond barre
celui ci va à l'encontre de la thèse
officielle qui veut que le corps n'ait
été découvert qu à 8h40
nous sommes procuré cette déclaration
dréossi qui donne à 3 heures du matin
dans la nuit un coup de téléphone par an
premiers à découvrir le corps du chioula
qui s'est suicidé c'est mon
collaborateur de garde
j'ai enseigné et qui me téléphonent
comme une voix me téléphoner surtout
quand il s'agit d'un ministre ne
pensions pas que le air avec sophie
poulin pourquoi ce décalage de cinq
heures qui ouvre la porte à toutes les
suspicions de manipulation
pour certains ce délai a peut-être
permis de maquiller un meurtre en
suicide
fabienne boulin cet après midi devrait
se voir communiquer les premiers
résultats des investigations menées par
la justice depuis cinq invités de ce 12
13 la fille de robert boulin fabienne
boulin-burgeat beaux jours vous étiez
déjà demandé en vain la réouverture de
l'anc est
vous pensez que ces nouveaux témoignages
vont faire la différence cette fois bien
écoutez c'est un combat difficile depuis
30 ans la thèse officielle reste
inchangée depuis 79 alors que des faits
nouveaux s'accumulent qui montre et
démontre qu'il s'agit bien d'un
assassinat
j'aimerais que la justice de mon pays il
courage de lever le voile de la vérité
sur cette affaire et cette fois ça vous
semble encore plus solide que la
dernière fois bien côté c'est très
solide parce qu'en plus il ya des
témoins de grande qualité que l'on ne
peut pas remettre en cause comme
monsieur mise sur bnl est fortement le
jean charbonnel site deux personnalités
politiques qui pourraient être impliqués
vous savez qui ça peut être maintenant
parce que je n'ai pas vu monsieur
charbonnel mois donc on en a pas discuté
mais
de toute façon moi je demande à la
justice de faire la vérité c'est 1000 il
faut bien sûr entendre ce témoin
laquelle capitale quand même et dans
votre for intérieur vous vous avez une
idée de qui aurait pu commandité cet
assassinat six assassinats liés pour
écouter je me doute en tout cas des
effectivement de en tout cas de
l'entourage et de ses biens que ces
politiques oui vous avez toujours
dénoncé un complot
aujourd'hui et des langues qui se
délient à votre a dit qui a intérêt
trente ans après à couvrir encore secret
mais un côté monsieur charbonnel dit que
ces personnalités qui seraient impliqués
dans l'assassinât sont toujours vivants
donc vous voyez
les assassins courent toujours et en
plus quand on peut re à la vérité sur
cette affaire
on montrera les vols laisse que les
enquêtes escamoter les voiles de sceller
les choses considérable qui montre que
notre de notre société est malade et
qu'il les temps peut-être que que on
nettoie les écuries d'augias
et qu'en face la vérité sur cet
assassinat et si la justice française
reste sourde à ce nouvel appel
jusqu'où êtes vous prête à aller mais
voilà donc s'il nous allons faire une
demande de réouverture et si celle ci
n'est pas acceptée on ira jusqu'à la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
bien entendu merci beaucoup
fabienne boulin burgeat d'avoir répondu
à notre invitation
[Musique]